what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey this is
unwaxed
we're going shopping with sophia and
sistine stallone we just become best
friends yup
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of unwaxed with your
favorite sister sophia
and sistine stallone hi guys
how are you how you doing did you have a
good breakfast
is it breakfast for them do you think
i'm gonna say it's breakfast how's your
car ride
are you going to work are you excited or
waiting out soon did you drink your
green tea today
we're getting off that caffeine guys
we're doing it together you know i hate
i hate people that tell me that i need
to start
drinking green tea over coffee when p
you know what i hate
when people tell me oh i don't drink
coffee i only drink
if you're a tea drinker i don't trust
them i trust you
i ain't totally sorry we're coffee like
coffee
freaks in our family when we we have
that coffee pot and we make it to the
full 14 cups and that pot
is gone within the first hour do you
understand what i have to do
i like to sleep in sophia what time are
you ask crack of dawn
yeah i'm up 6 37 so i hear sophia go
down the stairs right yeah and i know
she's getting that cup of coffee
right after she does that my mom does it
now if i decide
let me just sleep in 10 more minutes i'm
not getting a cup of coffee
so i literally have to drag wow our
problems right
i literally have to drag my ass out of
bed to beat you just to get a cup of
coffee
early bird gets the worm sistine early
bird
gets the worm and that means i get the
nice hot fresh cup of coffee but
scarlet's been drinking my almond
creamer and now i'm out
and he's driving me nuts the struggle
the struggle i'm facing this morning um
anyway you made a bomb dinner last night
oh yeah i want to just give you credit
let's talk about that you guys
i've been learning how to cook
now i've done maybe four meals for my
family
yeah three of which were extremely
unsuccessful you made
really really shitty turkey meatballs
that one time
they were they're heinous i've never
seen a meatball
melt into a pancake how did you
do that like it was so gross
it comes out of the oven and it is
pancakes it looks like a flapjack
and there were balls when we put it in
okay so yeah that one wasn't successful
i made a
few suspicious soups um but last night
let me tell you what i made you guys
i made baked potato which yes i know you
literally just have to stab it and throw
it in the oven there's literally zero
there's not so much but
but it was delicious so i did baked
sweet potatoes right
i made a white tuscan bean
soup unreal yeah okay a lot of prep
a lot of prep what else and then i made
a great kale salad with like a little
spicy
dijon ratatouille mustard vinaigrette oh
my god yeah you have been getting better
oh my god and you know what i've been
telling people i'm like i'm learning how
to cook and for some reason they
you know what they do no not only that
there's a different kind of
respect that you get if you actually can
say i know how to cook
notice how people's faces light up
they're like oh my god like that's
impressive
yeah a lot of people can't cook no i
think it's shocking i mean
i know i know i can cook i don't do it
as often as you do i think you've been
like way more adamant about like making
things
yeah and i think it's practice makes
perfect but it's just it
people just don't want to put in time
for the prep and that is really what it
is like going to the grocery store
buying all those mini like those little
ingredients you do need
oh my god it does i was looking for
something called
miso paste exactly for 20 minutes in the
market
never ended up finding it but yeah you
know what i was in there for
four hours cooking i think your soup
which i know you're like oh
soup how much how hard is it to make a
bean soup she has like 12 different
vegetables
it's an art yeah she's like artichoke
beans
carrots celery onions but
wanna do you want to talk about how you
didn't have
any of my dinner no i was busy i feel
like everyone's gonna think i'm lying
by the amount of dates i go on
i had a hamburger and red wine it was
delicious and i tried foie gras
what yeah i didn't know what it was and
the guy was like
it's great and i'm like i don't know it
looks like spam
different colors do you know what it is
no i don't even first of all
i don't even know what it is it just
sounds it's a french dish it's uh
it's a snail no that's a scarf this is
duck liver and it is it looks like
cestine
it looks like how do i explain it it
looks like
what our dogs used to eat the caesars
little food cups
and just you know how it's all hard and
you scoop it out and it can kind of
stay the same shape yeah i don't
understand how people see that and find
it appetizing
yeah well it came out in like these
little square
shapes and you cut it like it's it's so
crazy oh god and it had a little one
i know people are probably like i've had
photographs if you stop but no
i'm get this my first experience came
out with a little uh
toast and then had figs i think on the
side like
i like figs i liked fake jam so he was
like do it taste it
oh my god i want to like i don't want to
be a wimp so i'm like i'm gonna do it i
always i
i do taste things i'm like i'll try it
once well if i'm on a date with someone
i i will
you will do it just to seem like an
adventurous girl but inside i'm
literally
you you my stomach is turning i mean i
was curious but i was looking at this
and i'm a texture girl like with food
and [ __ ] knows it's like i like crunch
i like things i don't like
mush it's true sophia would rather eat a
snack that has no flavor but just has an
amazing
treat yeah yeah i have these beet chips
everyone makes fun of me and they're so
gross honestly they're like have no
flavor but i can hear her down the hall
eating it because they're so loud
because the texture
the texture is so nice but so i'm about
to put
this he's like here you gotta try it
you're gonna love it i'm like oh god
and i tried it and it
described the texture oh it was like oh
i don't even
i honestly it was a flavor i've never
had so i can't even explain it but i
definitely didn't love it
um but i also have to say like i
was like it wasn't as bad as i thought
it was gonna be but
after looking up and finding out it was
duck liver
that's like saying when you find out a
hot dog is all the
other stuff part of the pig into a you
know how
hot dogs are isn't it hot dogs
everything else but the
meat of the pig right excuse me all
ground up together
come again you know this
it's hot dogs are everything but
oh my god what about a pig in a blanket
same thing
um one long one shortening you look up
the hot dog fact i'm gonna update the
listeners on our
wild night out the other night because i
think it's
kind of funny um so sophia and i
uh our cousin came into town and it was
a blast and we said you know we gotta
show him a fun time let's go out to
dinner and let's just get a drink at a
bar and just have a good time right so
we
we get accidentally more drunk and i
don't know if anyone does that but it
happens where
you just stand up after you've been
sitting at the table
drinking eating your dinner and you're
like holy toledo
yeah it just hits you out of nowhere
this is the problem i think when it
comes to drinking there
you know there's a limit and you know
when your limit is
you stand up and you're like oh my gosh
i need to drink water
but for some reason that night
sophia i did the opposite i want to say
both of them were clear
they were both liquids i decided
to do the one that tasted like nothing
because i was um
sophia was the mvp of the night thank
you i'm not gonna lie
you were most you're mvb mvd
most valuable drunk and i'll tell you
why
i swear i'm not all of our no you're not
you just like to have a good time
all of our sort of memories from the
night before
came to us when we were at breakfast the
next day oh yeah yeah everything sort of
just hit us
yeah sophia while we were at dinner
don't remember this yeah i got an email
yeah
she got an order confirmation she
thought it would be a good idea
to drunkenly order family mood rings
now you may be asking what was the
context of that conversation
i couldn't tell i don't actually have i
cannot tell you why
i decided specifically family mood rings
we've never had a conversation like this
before
so and you bought all of our sizes yeah
i i
like got everyone's size so everyone has
ex
the perfect size movie right so you can
find it no one can tell me that they're
not excited for this
i think that was probably the but i also
don't
drunk order anything i would be wearing
my mood ring right now
if it came but i don't i don't ever do
that that was the first time i've ever
woken up all my girlfriends are like oh
i buy this and this and
you have a friend that just bought like
something funny and so yeah i mean
drunk ordering things are just the most
fun but
i always feel guilty for that even
though i didn't hurt anyone
i wasn't throwing up everywhere i wasn't
falling over can't a girl just have a
few drinks
and live time live her life but why do
we have this alcohol guilt like i don't
i don't want to feel guilty for saying
you know what i never drink throughout
the week
ever i'm like i'm gonna have one friday
special occasions
our family's in town yeah i you know
what i have severe alcohol guilt i don't
know why
i try to fight the feeling of a hangover
so bad like i simply my brain and my
body will not allow me to relax
if i am dying the next day after
drinking and i don't know why it is
sometimes you're just like okay
you had a crazy night out take a day
yeah i feel guilty for taking time to
relax and rest i don't
know why and it's like me too i i never
drink and when i do it's maybe once a
week we'll have a fun
night out but dude i get the guilt
like the fact i'm like explaining all
the stuff i did and i'm sitting here
like thinking about it and i feel
embarrassed but i'm like why do i
why do i feel embarrassed about it you
know i'm if you ever want to go out with
me
i'm fun to go out with you might get
hurt you know what sophia and i
actually wanted to do this in the very
beginning of the
unwaxed podcast saga we
thought it would be really funny to
bring in our drunk alter egos and have
them run the show
oh yeah and so her drunk alter ego name
is bambi exactly what you might think
think about
bambi when she's on ice yep and that's
sophia like her ankles just stop working
my drunk alter ego is named tina
don't know why her name's tina tina tina
gets
a little air heady and tina gets a
little
sassier tina has no
sense of right and wrong no but we will
both be on the table
you will be falling off but we will both
be on the table so maybe we'll do that
one day
we will i think that'd be kind of funny
to work you know to move past our drunk
guilt yes exactly
um should we talk about our guests that
we have oh my god i mean you can
introduce her since you
want her to come on which is so sick
very exciting you guys we haven't had
a proper guest of course we've had
family members make their appearances
these past few episodes but we really
haven't had
a full-on first-time meeting interview
in a long time and it's so exciting we
cannot wait
we have dr sheila nazarian coming on she
is a plastic surgeon you may have
recognized her from the netflix show
skin decisions before and after it's on
netflix i mean it is
such a good conversation we talk about
everything from
what girls do on instagram for their
bodies we talk about
how to be a boss woman we talk about i
mean it is we go
everywhere i mean we talk about how to
stand up to someone that's doubting your
abilities because they perceive you a
certain way and we we talk about plastic
surgery
what you should do now to take better
care of your skin
your body your hair everything and you
we learned a lot from her and she is
such a badass and i'm so
so glad you guys are here to listen to
yeah because this is a real tree and she
really killed it and this is her doctor
sheila nazarian is not only a mom
wife entrepreneur and a board-certified
plastic surgeon
specializing in natural results using
both non-invasive
and surgical modalities she also has an
amazing netflix series called
skin decisions with a following over 500
000 on instagram
she's an activist shares wellness tips
and step-by-step procedures
she does everything this is dr sheila
nissarion
hey guys hi thank you so much for coming
on on wax today i mean
you are such an exciting guest for us to
have
honestly oh my god you're so sweet well
you like checking out you guys profiles
no but i swear you really you know what
i think it is no seriously
i think like when you can put an
instagram caption that's less than three
words and get like
20 000 likes on it that's when you know
you made it that's when you
made it that's when you made it you
really check all of the boxes of like a
guest that we'd love to have on the show
a female a boss woman a mom i mean an
activist you really do it all so we're
so happy you're hilarious
yeah you're like not only that you have
a great personality so
the everything just looks badass you're
great so we're so excited to have you
juan i mean sistine and i
we saw the show skin decisions and from
then on out
it was definitely one of those
quarantine binges
and we probably saw every single episode
in two days
i want to know so many things about the
show i mean
when did they offer it to you what was
the shooting process like having cameras
in the room
what was that all like no i mean it was
definitely like a saga to get a tv show
and that was definitely my goal since
residency i remember i was like a fifth
year plastic surgery resident
and one of the attendings was like so
like where do you see yourself in five
years i'm like i'm gonna have a tv show
and yeah and he's looked at me like okay
weirdo like
whatever um but i feel like every single
person has their own unicorn right i
feel like there's
so many plastic surgeons in my building
alone my my
my building not even beverly hills
there's in my building 31 plastic
surgery oh my god
wow so it's like you know we all can do
a breast augmentation we can all do a
tummy tuck but it's like what is your
unicorn like what sets you apart from
everybody else and i think that can be
applied to anyone in any business
yeah so for me it's like i communicate
clearly and
i'm personable which a lot of people
definitely are
and also like i'm good on camera and
i've been you know
when i first came out of residency
nobody knew who i was like nobody knew
my name so i just started creating
content
and like answering frequently asked
questions on youtube
my seo you know showing up on the first
page of google shot up after two years
on
i was on the first page of google if you
search
which is like again how many plastic
surgeons are in beverly hills like the
car lot
and um no i just started creating
content so for me having cameras in the
room wasn't a big deal at all but
i actually went through um a few pilots
uh i was actually under contract with e
for a year
they decided not to pick up that show
but actually the producer from
that show that never got picked up um
was the one that approached me for skin
decisions so it was almost like you know
you spread that knit wide
it came full
that you can send this i mean that this
is a show that people want to see
because it just kind of takes away the
whole
stereotype of plastic surgery from it
being just plastic to it really changing
lives well that's why
i mean if the listeners out there if you
guys haven't seen the show
it is not your generic plastic surgery
botched type
show it's not about exploiting people's
sort of insecurities
it's more about giving them a second
chance and giving them like
you know a resurrection in their own
skin again and i found myself
crying i mean the stories of people that
you got to work on it was like
someone got a bullet hole wound and
someone was a slashing attack scars i
mean
they were really special cases so seeing
you you know firsthand just
completely changed these people's lives
was amazing i mean what did that feel
like
no i mean that's definitely like what we
do you know as plastic surgeons it's not
the circus that
it's made out to be on tv my patients
are super empowered women that just need
help with something like they're already
successful
they've they already work out they eat
well and they just like
had you know quadruplets or something
and they can't work off the skin hanging
off their belly or
whatever whatever it is and you know it
doesn't have to be even that
it could just be like a labiaplasty it
could be someone who doesn't like the
way their vagina looks and that's okay
and i think
there was two intentions i had with the
show is basically to
show plastic surgery as a part of
self-care
rather than um this you know taboo thing
that you have to keep secret it's also
to give permission to people
to say you know what this bothers me a
lot and i'm going to fix it because it's
safe
and i just don't want to have to think
about that anymore i don't want to have
to
i totally agree i think sophia and i we
had a plastic surgeon on the show
right when we sort of started on waxing
and we asked her we said why is it such
a
scared topic that people are almost
afraid to admit that they got it done i
mean it's not like
you know you're doing something that's
against the law it's plastic surgery and
you're fixing something that'll make you
feel better and make you feel happier
when you wake up so
do you think that this sort of norm is
changing as younger people are starting
to get i hope it
is and i feel like it is to some extent
but then at the same time like i can
tell when someone's had their butt done
and i see you know influencers your age
you know squatting with weights like
down into the camera
being like i do squats and that's why my
butt looks this way and i'm like [ __ ]
no
like don't don't say that to people
because you see the young girls out
there
are like doing a thousand squats and
starving themselves and thinking they're
going to get that body
i this was the first thing i wrote down
when i wanted to interview you i said
she really wrote inspires
reality i am one of those girls that
will be on instagram
look at all of the workout girls copy
down their exact workout that they post
in the caption
trying to get their perfect bubble butt
and
i do it for weeks i do for months i eat
like them and i'm like hold on i'm just
hungry and
my butt got smaller so what did i do
wrong here so i would love to know
is it real like the girls especially the
workout girls promoting like their
perfect body no i will tell you the
secret are you ready
can we drum roll like if they don't have
hip dips they had work done
that's it it's so easy if they don't
have hip dips
that's not real so how does that how
does a procedure like that even happen
like what would you do for someone i
mean there's different ways to do it so
you can either liposuction fat from like
you know your waist
or your inner thighs and then stick it
into the hip dips which i do all the
time
you know it makes the waist look smaller
um it gives a nice little upside down
heart
kind of you know look to the butt um and
also
you know a lot of times people look like
they have saddle bags but they don't
they just have a massive dip
above it right so when you feel that dip
it kind of just makes everything smooth
you can do it with filler um there's
what we call biostimulatory fillers that
aren't like the filler you put in your
lips
they actually make your own body create
either fat or collagen or both
so that over time as you get it injected
you
start to build your own collagen and fat
in those areas that you were missing it
before
now let me tell you you would think that
the filler option would be a lot cheaper
it's not it's actually
much more expensive because you actually
have i buy that stuff off the shelf
so it's like you're going through a
middleman versus getting lipo
you're kind of almost getting like a
twofer right you're getting fat
away from where you don't want it and
you're using your own fat to put it
where you do want it so actually the
surgery ends up being cheaper a lot of
the times
and that's because sistine's always
talking about butts specifically that i
always go into stomachs because i feel
like that's a big thing right now too is
you look at some of these girls that we
just idolize on instagram
and they have these giant asses and
these super flat stomachs
and i worked with this girl and she does
a lot of these massages and she was like
if you look at a lot of these girls
they all kind of have the same stomach
where they have a belly full a belly
button fold
or there's something like that i mean is
that kind of like the long-term effects
if you
do lipo on your stomach and take away
that like extra thing
no it's just like a skin laxity thing
over time
all of our skin especially lighter skin
tones tend to have thinner skin than
darker skin types
um you know as the skin gets locks
that's when you get that little like
fold of you know a little
hanging skin above the belly button
could you get that from liposuction
because you deflated it right yes you
would
um but there's also so many like
modalities right now like radio
frequency that can help tighten that
skin i do it on my own stomach all the
time
oh i want to try it honestly i've seen
those we are so up to trying anything
yeah
i mean honestly let's do it all let's do
it all right
so what is sort of a telltale sign that
someone's gotten work done
so we we sort of discussed the upside on
looking belly button
how can and the the hip dips that aren't
there so how how can you really tell
i mean you know i think a lot of times
too on instagram things look good
like high def lipo when they like will
actually like etch a six pack
with liposuction they can do that yeah i
mean i think it can look really good i
kind of like a medium depth look where
it's kind of like
look defined but your own muscle is
showing through yeah but the high def
you know sometimes on instagram it looks
good but in real life it looks like
somebody took a sharpie to your stomach
so um i see and to
put out there and this is like an idea
for another show that i have is to
actually bring in
these young influencers and you know
show how they're
tuning their bodies like you guys these
girls that you're following on instagram
i treat a lot of them
and i mean a lot of them right
and a lot of them have liposuction scars
which is fine
yeah it's like you do have to have a
certain body shape but a lot of them are
are like bringing their hips out they
they just do it on like facetune or an
app like that
so even the girls that are getting
worked on are still
like doing things to their photos yeah
and it's not even that with just even
plastic surgery it's also
the skin treatments they do like that i
know that i've i went to one place
where it was this trend that everyone
was doing like this i forgot what it was
called this like skin tightening
machine it doesn't work i know it's
formal i mean it works it works but like
for like a second right like you have to
do it every week every week but
it's thousands and thousands and
thousands of dollars to keep it up and
going
and you're like oh my god how do these
girls have like flawless tight skin and
it does work if you're consistent
but like no one can afford that and
you're just no i put so many other thing
too
yeah it's like what kind of messaging
are we as plastic surgeons putting out
there it's like yeah we want to put out
messaging so you know we have successful
practices but at the same time
how do we stay ethical and right um
realize that you know we're putting out
this like standard of beauty
that most people cannot afford right
right so
it's like i could say use medical grade
skin care but what if people can and we
know that that works
right meanwhile people are spending 5.99
9.99
on stuff at the drugstore that doesn't
work so
do you save up and buy the one thing
that actually will make a difference
or do you feel like oh that smells good
and it's creamy
so that makes me feel like i'm doing
self-care which has some value too
but you're not going to see real changes
so have you figured out that happy
medium for someone that
can't afford this super expensive and
doesn't want to spend their money on the
cheap jug
so i started um theskinspot.com so it's
literally three words the skinspot.com
like seven years ago
and it's all medical grade skin care
which is cool because since i'm a
physician i'm allowed to dispense it
online whereas
companies aren't allowed to carry a lot
of the brands that i'm able to bring
and there are high lows you know there
are brands that tend to be
more expensive um like if they have stem
cells in them and stuff like that but
then there's brands that actually have
great
great ingredients niacinamides retinols
you know all that stuff that are the
lower price point but the point is like
whether you're spending a lot or a
little
there should be studies behind the
skincare you shouldn't be buying it
because an influencer got paid to tell
you to buy it
so this is what i was trying to like
come like full circle is when you're
profiting off people
for like doing things in fitness and
eating habits and all of this stuff when
you've done
all of the opposite which is getting
paid to surgeries or like you're paying
for surgeries and you're paying for
these treatments and
i mean i'm not asking influencers or
anybody to be a hundred percent honest
24 7 because
you know it's you're just they don't
sound like you don't have to it's not
i mean it is also like uncomfortable to
talk about and i mean it
unfortunately i wish it wasn't so
awkward to bring up because it's just a
surge
it's not like you did something wrong
it's something you just wanted to have
done
but just when you profit off of other
people's insecurities
and using that saying like i'm natural
i'm perfect if that's when you cross the
line so are most of your clients
sort of brought in through your
instagram because you do have such a
strength
no um i i'm like a data psychopath um
so i know exactly where every dollar
comes in from because i also went to
business school so
um most of my uh profit actually comes
from google
um so seo yeah search engine
observations and then
you know i do have a large following
and not as large as you guys but you
know a large large for a doctor
well largely
like that also helps with search engine
optimization
so like pinterest at this point even
though like no one's on pinterest right
like me
i have about 10 bucks like bathroom
remodels and stuff
but during covid's pinterest like peaked
for skincare
wow so hope it's not even a social app
anymore it's literally search engine
optimization that is what it is
and you know utilizing things and having
knowledge of those things like
everything you do on social media social
media announced 50
of search engine optimization so having
that it's like the better the content
you put out the more
you know google's going to reward you so
yeah i um
would love to know what when you started
what trends of plastic surgery were
popular versus
what is so popular today because my mom
always says you know
she was like a model in the 80s and 90s
and she's like everyone wanted the giant
yeah yeah giant breasted like and no no
and now it's the complete opposite so
what was it like
that's what i was going to say i think
the biggest change i've seen is the
breasts and i mean obviously the butt
um people were getting liposuction of
their butt like 20 years ago and now
they're coming
in no and i honestly guys i just thought
that was nuts like to begin with and
that's sort of where like the natural by
nazarian came into place because your
clothes
like you know when you're this is the
best analogy i can give you you know
when you like buy a couch they tell you
buy a neutral couch and then you can
change the pillows
right right that's great so same thing
with your body like just be well
proportioned and you can change your
clothes but you shouldn't be like
changing your body every 10 years
okay so you're you specialize in very
natural
yeah we wanted to make like look like
very proportional god-given
and then donate your clothes and buy new
ones you know but you shouldn't be like
liposuctioning your butt now you're
putting fat back into your butt you put
big breast implants now you're getting
small breast implants well i'm sure that
just that
wear and tear over the years can like
really do a number on someone's body
yeah i think like yeah yeah i don't know
i just think it's
doesn't sound right to me to be getting
to be under the knife every five to ten
years
you should be doing stuff all the time
to like boost collagen
and keep your skin right and you should
be exercising and eating well and doing
all those things
and plastic surgery has a place in that
because there's certain things you can't
work out off and that's right it goes
into like talking about
tips and tricks because i know people
obviously there's things that we should
probably do every day religiously even
in our twenties so when we're
in our family absolutely what are like
for 20 year olds what are some good
things they should start working on now
when it comes to skin care or
whether it comes to body health or even
taking certain vitamins
yeah yeah no i mean i take like 20
vitamins today
it's a little ridiculous but do you
believe because some people don't
believe in vitamins working
but i think they do they work right they
absolutely work like i take hair
vitamins and literally it's changed my
hair
well i would like to touch on that
because yeah i had
an issue um some would say it's an
addiction in the beginning of the
pandemic and you had like eyes 20
milligrams
took probably
maybe 13 biotin gummies and let me tell
you guys biotin is not
the end-all be-all biotin's like one
little thing
that helps hair but it can make you
break out oh break out i looked like
wrongful still skin it was horrible
it was throwing hair everywhere i wasn't
just first of all i was growing
i was looking like a sasquatch and i had
acne and i stopped taking biotin i was
like okay now my nails aren't growing as
fast but
no but literally let me tell you like
there's um we have vitamins that are on
the skin spot
that are actually evidence-based
your influencers getting paid whatever
like literally we want like scientific
studies
okay like i up seeing the hair follicle
at the root like that's what i look for
because i was going to tell you like i
was talking to one of my influencer
friends and she's like
if i like advertise a curling iron and
it's not the best curling iron then no
one's gonna die
okay but me with an md after my name if
i advertise something that's crap
right like people get hurt like you know
because i'm true
you know advertising a curling iron so
what vitamins do you recommend
going back to this question what
treatment yeah so for hair i mean
nutrafall i think
is the absolute best um it's on the site
um
if you get it in the three pack it's
pretty affordable it comes out to like
thirty dollars
ish i don't know maybe more i don't know
but it's worth it because it works
yeah and why i love it too it's got a
ton of turmeric in it which is
anti-inflammatory it's just like
all the all the things like anti-cancer
yeah like it's good for you anyway like
we should all be taking that you know we
should all be on turmeric
yeah no so that one i take you know
every single day i take a dim
um which is basically dim is basically
um
one that if your cells are choosing to
go the cancerous route or not
it pushes them through the knot oh
that's really important
i take a d vitamin a vitamin d vitamin k
um i take a probiotic i mean i'm just
like literally good for you
that's great no i've been taking
probiotics and that actually has changed
my body
a lot i have a question this might be
weird my mom said i should
even though i'm not trying to get
pregnant right now i am 22.
uh yeah she said that i should take
prenatal vitamins just because they're
full
of a ton of vitamins and good things is
that weird to start taking now
it's not weird no it's not weird but
honestly at this point like just
you know you have to also look at the
back of the ingredients too because a
lot of them have similar ingredients so
you're like
overdosing on things like biotin
5000 milligrams of like whatever or
something like that we go from zero to
hundred we don't like slowly transition
into doing anything we kind of just like
do it
well we also look for the flavored
gummies oh yeah that is true
we look for like the ones are covered in
sugar and then we realize that all that
sugar
is breaking us out and it doesn't work
well in our stomachs
sugar is like toxic no as i'm drinking a
red bull
sugar-free though sugar-free um okay so
what about lasers
i mean how effective are lasers for skin
amazing so
you know because again like i'm kind of
like an influencer in the beauty space
i basically get my pick of lasers so i
always tell people no matter whether
you're in this country even or not just
go on my website look at the devices
section
and those are the lasers you want okay
because for every one laser that's on my
website i've personally tried three or
four on my own body
so oh man see if i was you and we were
in that office i would just sit there
and do lasers
all over myself all day i mean how great
would that you think you would but it's
so busy like
sometimes i'll go months and months
without even getting like you know
injected for
wrinkles because it's just like by the
end of the day i'm like oh
okay so that actually okay i've never
done um botox or anything like that
before and
some of my girlfriends have already
started and i'm 24 25.
um is there like a certain time that you
should start doing it that's just let's
start now
oh really i already see like when you
were just turned a little bit you know
you're already starting to get a little
something something and it's not bad you
guys but i'll give you a little secret
like i started when i was 28 um and
that's just because we were practicing
on each other like we were in residency
but now you know i'm 41 and
all my friends that look younger or look
good for
my friends group yeah somebody told them
to start at 20 like somebody
in their 20s somebody like gave them the
secret either their mom worked for a
plastic surgeon or their mom was an
esthetician or something
okay but this really is especially for
lighter skin tones is start in your 20s
what about the way if i wanted to do it
there's so many questions
what it is i feel like people because i
have some girlfriends that even ask me
like when would you start i'm like i
don't know
the average age of botox is 25. it's 20.
there we go
not in l.a like in the country that
means some people are starting when
they're 20 and some people are starting
with how do i do it without
totally freezing my face because i'm
also something that is just a dosage
it's like when you have a headache do
you take a full tylenol or half a
tylenol
right also botox helps with migraines
which i have a lot of migraines
yeah then you should definitely it'll be
good okay i have no migraines but i'll
be right
there i will be right by your side um so
i think that a lot of women
and some men have been you know using
this time
in covid to sort of get these procedures
on because they have a lot of time to
heal
so have you not used that like you can
get a facelift and wear a mask and
nobody knows
exactly that's the i mean that's the
brilliant part but are people coming in
as i wish i was at this time that i
needed a face lifter give us five years
everything it was five years
um have you found some patients coming
in saying you know like i see myself
on the zoom computer and i don't like
the way it looks so have you been
changing
you know just based off of how they look
on a computer yeah i mean you know how
like zoom it's basically like the
camera's coming up kind of under your
neck we've definitely seen a shift
in lower face procedures whether it's
minimally invasive
or you know full surgical procedure or
just lasers for tightening along the
jawline
or even fillers to like pronounce the
jawline we've been seeing a lot of
people coming in for that
everyone's been obsessed with a lot of
these um singers influencers all of it
and they have this extremely sharp
jawline and i
remember cysteine and i it does not
exist
the sharpest jaw in the world i know the
trick of like swallowing
yeah yeah like sucking i don't know how
to do this i know i know how to do
photos like that so i
trick everyone i'm like whatever but i
know right now
that some people like how do i get to
that like how would i fill it in and
sometimes that's part of your neck like
unless you get a procedure
to get rid of i heard like that part of
your neck
i mean you can definitely all of us have
some fat there
and also some people have a weak chin so
if you have a weak chin it sort of
leaves a little skin hanging whereas if
you just got chin filler it would kind
of pull that skin
forward so i think there's a lot of
different like anatomical considerations
in the lower face and for me i look at
every
you know aesthetic patient as like
what's their diagnosis
so you know when you go to the doctor
they're like do you have diabetes do you
have high blood pressure like
what is your diagnosis i i look at
someone's face or breasts or whatever it
is and i say okay what am i looking at
what's the diagnosis
right and there's different treatments
for different problems
so is there something that you would
absolutely turn away like a patient came
to you and said i want to do this
have you ever like i mean honestly it's
hilarious because people
um i think patients are like oh you're
the you know the third plastic surgeon
i'm meeting with and they think they're
interviewing me but no i'm interviewing
you
yeah like that's okay that's true i'm
not hungry
mama's not starving my cell phone number
and therefore
i'm constantly asking myself two
questions do i want this person to have
my cell phone number
right and who are they capable of
happiness
because if you're incapable of happiness
there's no way i can make you happy
they'll never be satisfied yeah so i
just turned people away i just refunded
someone twenty five thousand dollars
wow for a surgery because i was like
you're not you're not ready to receive
happiness right now what type of surgery
was it if you don't is it
i think it was like liposuction fat
transfer or maybe like a breast lift
okay so being happy that's such a i've
never heard that
being even like correlated with your
practice no no not in that way that
sounds terrible but you know no i know
i'm sorry you're saying
but you genuinely care about the patient
and
it's not just that like it's not just
caring about the patient you want happy
patients
right why would i operate on someone
that i know
no matter what i do it's not going to
save their marriage or no matter what i
do
that guy telling them something about
their boobs when she was 15.
like i'm never going to be able to fix
that like i have people come in with
like micro photos of like how they're
how another plastic surgeon messed them
up and i'm looking at them being like
you look great
yeah right it's like there's no way i
can make you happy if that result
doesn't make you happy would you ever
because i've i've had some my
girlfriends uh mentioned to me like
or not my girlfriends but i've had like
heard stories about girls getting
commented by like guys saying that they
don't look great down there and
then i want to get plastic surgery from
that have you ever had those scenarios
just because i know
some guys can be cruel porn industry is
just like
so [ __ ] realistic unrealistic and
have you ever had that situation where
girls come up to you and said like
i'm really really insecure because
someone's made a comment on it i'm like
comparing myself to them and i think the
only time somebody said those like exact
words to me
was um it was a pilot for a show um and
i turned her down
because it was fine um but no i i think
in general i think
you know with branding as you guys know
what whatever you project or whatever
you put out there is what is going to
be attracted to you so i put out such
like a strong
female boss lady kind of thing that
that's sort of the type of patient
population that i attract
i've never had someone bring in a
picture of a celebrity
ever really ever what plastic surgeon
says that
right right so literally people just
come in they're like i want to look like
myself i just want to look optimized
i want to look like myself i just want
to be refreshed nobody comes in and
they're like
this bella hadid's eyes like people
don't come to me with that
okay i'm gonna pick up on that i'm gonna
pick up on that little that little
comment there because i have a question
a lot of these
models have these snatched fox eye
lifted faces is this from threading i've
heard threading is the
um for the models it's from surgery
it's like a little facelift i'm assuming
they've had they've had like a little
yeah is that what happens after okay so
they get it young and it's fine it looks
great like if you wanted to get it
all all good but after a couple years
when you're getting older and your skin
is actually starting to age
does something happen where they have to
redo that whole thing or is it i mean if
you want the same look you know we never
stop
aging right so i always even a facelift
a full facelift lasts like eight to ten
years and they have to redo
oh yeah because your skin continues to
stretch
right you know even if you do radio
frequency and tightening no no well
that's the thing like that's what we're
thinking now it's like let's see how far
we can push this now because
all the radio frequency stuff's been out
for like five six years right
so now all my face of patients i try to
explain to them i'm not
changing the quality of your skin by by
doing a surgery
but these modalities can change the
quality of your skin so that's why a
maintenance program is needed
to maintain your results and i have all
of them on it now me so far so good but
only time will tell
right i would love to transition a
little bit
and talk about sort of your
experience coming up in this male
dominated
industry you know i again like we
mentioned we had the prior
plastic surgeon come on the show and she
said
practicing when i was starting was being
a woman
x on you being pretty exxon you bring
smart accent
like and wanting to be a mom with a
husband like it just were all things
that
basically everyone was saying was
unobtainable yet you obtained all of
them
yeah was it i would love to know some of
your highs and lows like how hard it was
for you
and maybe like something that helped you
push forward like a quote
or something that you always say to
yourself when you feel like you're you
know
i think the thing that pushed me forward
was kind of proving people wrong
and i think that can be a very strong
motivator when people tell you you can't
you're like watch me
but at the same time i don't think it's
healthy to let that be your motivator
forever
yeah so i think as of like five six
years ago i was like okay i did
everything i said i was gonna do now i'm
gonna really make decisions based off of
my quality of life and what makes me
happy and what fulfills me
so i think it's good to sort of you know
get that drive
um based off of like proving people
wrong but at the same time at some point
you got to let that go
um but you know coming up i think i was
so exhausted
and so um busy and working so
hard i kind of didn't even i wasn't even
aware of anyone being like oh you're a
girl
but after i graduated and started to
become successful
you know there's a saying that like you
know people want you to be successful
but not more successful than them
right wow i think i felt that a lot and
me posting pictures of myself like i
love
clothes i love fashion but in when i was
coming out it kind of wasn't
um considered ethical to do any kind of
advertising
so um me doing pictures and gowns on
social media i mean there were literal
board meetings
um at our societies talking about how i
use unfair tactics to gain followers
me in a gown is an unfair tactic how is
that unfair yeah
i don't understand the thing because i
don't know i honestly don't know but
it's just like you know can the men do
that
no you were a suit and they're like oh
no you're okay too handsome
yeah that's see but that's that's
ridiculous and
so you know and i mean i got shot on so
much like
so much so how did you how did you push
through that you know because a lot i
think a lot of people and i know we can
certainly relate to
even like people that we thought were
our friends like kick
down and people they really don't have
our back and don't want us to succeed
they make assumptions just because we
are we have a certain last name or we
have a certain following and we're in a
type of industry where they think oh
they're probably not that intellectual
just because they do a certain
career so what kind of driving you i
think
um you got to know kind of who you are
on the inside
and you got to have your core values
really straight
and once you know who you are and you
know whose opinions you actually do care
about and i always say like you should
only care about people's opinions if
they want to see you succeed
if somebody rather see you fall flat on
your face why are you spending time and
energy caring about what that person
thinks
right and that didn't come to me
naturally you know i'm a middle eastern
girl
where we're i don't know like what
italians are like but like it was
basically like you were supposed to be a
good girl
like you lived to be patted on the head
and told what a good girl you are
right so it took me a minute to be like
you know what i don't need anybody
else's approval i know who i am my
husband knows who i am my kids love me i
have a healthy marriage and a healthy
family
my dad's proud of me and that's pretty
much all right you got your tribe
literally like this weekend i got mean
girls by like a bunch of injectors
um because i was injecting my own face
and they're like what are you doing
blah blah blah
we're gonna come after you if you don't
take that down i was like i'm gonna [ __ ]
wait why would why would you have to
take i love that energy
there's a lot of people like
self-injecting illegally right now and
i'm like so does that mean like
if i show you know a brazilian butt lift
like me injecting fat into the butt
that's going to make someone go buy
silicone from home depot and check
like no if they weren't going to do it
to begin with seeing me do it in a
surgery isn't going to make him do it no
there's no way you can ever make
everyone happy yeah but like people come
if somebody comes at me with like a
threat they're going to get like
like oh so you you're like
we're like little bulldogs we are
bulldogs honestly i always say i'm a
lion i'm like don't go after the lion
good for you i love it honestly
individually we're not like that
together it's scary no and i like that i
let you know what it is is that i like
that you speak up because
that's what we need to start doing and
especially when it comes to people
bullying or sit not
treating someone with respect like treat
others the way you want to be treated i
don't understand why i
think it takes a lot more work to be
mean to someone than it is to people
sure yeah i just don't know where all
that energy comes from
but i i like their upbringing it comes
from their parents
it comes you know like look at the kids
in school like if the kids
uh you know mean girl it's because their
mom's a [ __ ] my mom says this my mom's
like if there's a kid that was bullying
you guys at school
i'm not blaming the kid i'm looking at
the parent because obviously
the parent isn't raising the kids it's a
with love and kindness
they're just a product maybe it's not
even boundaries maybe it's too much love
and kindness maybe it's not
like enough grounding like we've seen
both
we've seen both but i like that you are
so strong
and you're just a strong female and
you're also it's inspiring for a lot of
women it's exciting for me it's
inspiring for me too because i know that
there have been moments where i'm like
[ __ ] i should have spoken up
and i'm happy you did and i'm i'm really
excited that you're here
what's the best team is um when somebody
i actually give a talk on this turning
your haters into motivators i have a
have a non-profit too called think big
okay it's under
but actually have a talk that i just
gave as a keynote too i'm giving it
again in vegas this weekend um
but it's called turning your haters into
motivators and two of the best things to
do when somebody says something shitty
to you
is the first thing is just ask them to
repeat it louder say i'm sorry can you
say that a little bit louder
and then they're like that's number one
and number two
is like you want to ask like ask return
the question with your question so for
example one time i was getting off of
stage
after i gave a talk and this guy was
like i don't know why they asked you to
give that talk and i was like well who
should they have asked you
so answer it with an answer with a
question
just well because it turns about i love
it because i got chills no but seriously
when people i think when they spit out
hey they're not really thinking about
what they're saying
and then you ask them to repeat and like
oh [ __ ] that really sounded bad
and they have to have a lot of cojonas
to be like
yeah that's what i said they never
repeat it
oh my god i love that louder in the mic
like
you're like get back on scene wait i'm
sorry can i snapchat it do one more time
for my following
no that that's amazing so you're you
also you're like a
motiva motivational speaker jeez that's
it it's just sort of like things that
i've learned
you know and honestly like i look at my
instagram i look at
you know the teaching that i do and all
that and i look at it as a diary for my
kids
you know it's sort of like something
that they can go back and be like oh
yeah how old are your kids i have i
you will not believe i don't even
believe it my eldest daughter just
applied to my high school like
that means you're old oh my god
so i have a 14 year old uh 12 girl a 12
year old boy and a 9 year old girl
oh my god i love the mix that's perfect
that means you're you're going to have a
good boy because he's got sisters to
keep him in check
we're working on him we're working on
he's adorable he's adorable
he's like he really wants a cell phone
i'm like well you have to show maturity
by being nice to your sisters and be
like
there we go can i get one strike i'm
like yeah you can get one
could i be mean one time yeah oh that's
so cute well thank you so much for
coming on the show today i mean
i i could continue this conversation
forever but i know you're a busy woman
but we really do really do appreciate it
please plug
all of your info your instagram so
everyone can find you
no sure um i think the best thing is i
have a link tree with all of my links on
my main instagram
it's uh dr sheila nazarian so dr sheila
nazarian
and then if you go to the link in bio
you'll see everything
okay perfect thank you again for coming
out thank you we love you so nice to
meet you
we're gonna we'll see you in your office
very soon that sounds good we'll see you
there
bye bye bye from all of us here at the
show
thanks for staying unwaxed
be sure to download new episodes every
tuesday on apple podcasts
spotify or podcastone.com follow your
hosts
at sophia stallone and at sistine
stallone and be sure to follow the show
at unwaxed podcast your producer is will
sterling
we'll see you next week